[Music]
hey everyone
welcome back today i am excited to bring
you
an excerpt from a much larger video i
made
on the topic of baroque ornamentation
and that video was actually made in
collaboration with
tonebase if you don't know already
tonebase is this really
fantastic website that brings you
lessons
and tutorials from some of the world's
leading classical guitarists
and actually some of my personal guitar
heroes really
also by the way if you use the promo
code brandon
30 you can save 30 to subscribe and see
all sorts of wonderful
content on there check out the the link
in the description if you
if you want to learn more so today i'd
like to show you a clip
in which i answer the question can we
ornament
the music of johann sebastian bach
[Music]
often i think guitarists are
apprehensive about ornamenting bach
they don't know if they're allowed they
don't know if they should and i want to
say
yes you should we should treat bach
like any baroque composer in that in
this style
ornamentation is obligatory however
what makes bach a bit different is that
he's very explicit
in his notation often he writes out
ornaments
in notes that would have been just
referred to with a symbol
or perhaps even just implied by the
melody in fact bach is even hilariously
criticized
in 1737 by a guy named johan adolph
shaiba
who says he writes out with precise
notes
all ornaments all small graces and all
that one understands his good style of
playing
and this deprives his pieces not only of
the beauty of the harmony but it also
makes the melody completely
unrecognizable
now that says a lot obviously we
modern people are happy though this
gives us some insight
into what they consider to be the
implied good ornamentation
practice in the baroque period so to
finish today
i thought we could take everything we've
learned and apply them
to the opening of the lure from the e
major partita by bach
now i'm playing this on the 13 course
baroque loot
in f major though because i'm at 4 15
pitch
that actually means it sounds as modern
e major
so feel free to play along we're going
to start by looking at the violin
version
which doesn't have much ornamentation
written in just two trills
in the beginning let's start by just
hearing how it goes without
any ornamentation
now you might notice i'm using a bit of
swing actually
the eighth notes if played exactly as
written would be
[Music]
but there's a concept called note in a
gal which means
unequal notes are uneven notes
and this is kind of actually like modern
jazz swing instead of going
one and two and three and four and we
get
one and two and three and four and
and this would be appropriate to use in
this dance
now before we add any extra ornaments we
have to be careful
remember that critique from shaiba about
bach writing out
ornaments in the beginning of the fourth
complete measure
we have secret ornaments there's a
cadence sort of a dominant to tonic
cadence
to use modern terminology of five to a
one chord b major
to e major in the original key bach
ornaments this within pogchatura
[Music]
so there's a little secret ornament and
in the second half of the bar
bach takes this very simple one chord
with a falling third in the melody and
he decorates it with an ornament
which is called the tiers coulee it's
essentially two appoggiaturas
okay now that we've searched for any
hidden ornaments
we can add the two trills bach writes in
let's remember that we play them from
the upper note
and now we start to get a better sense
of how this is going to go
now we could simply walk through the
piece and
try out the variety of essential
ornaments and see
what works when oh i like this one there
oh this part's fine by itself
and we could just decide on which
ornaments to play when and maybe even
play it differently in each performance
but i do have a bit of surprise it turns
out that
later after publishing this violin
partita bach had adapted
this work for a keyboard and
in that version he added many apocaturas
and so let's see what that sounds like
so are we done i don't think so there's
so much more room
for ornamentation here some ideas could
be
turning the appogiaturas
into trills
you could add extra appoggiaturas um if
you
read a bit about this arbitrary
ornamentation kwanzaa's second style
you could fill in the leaves could
become
why not
[Music]
let's try an ornamented version on the
guitar
[Music]
[Music]
you